this program is being presented to you
by the Harris international winter
school on gravity and lights welcome to
the third tutorial of the w/e Helios
International winter school on gravity
and light
today's topic is multi linear algebra
and again we want to start with fifteen
statements which may either be true or
false what space at what statements on
vector spaces are correct commutativity
of multiplication is a vector space
axiom no it's not commutativity of
addition is one but commutativity of
multiplication follows from the
commutativity of multiplication on the
field that underlies so this is
incorrect every vector space is a matrix
with only one column false as well since
we had the example of polynomials up to
some finite degree which constituted a
vector space and these are definitely
not a matrix with only one column every
linear map between vector spaces can be
represented by a unique quadratic matrix
this would be true if the dimensions of
both vector spaces were the same but
here the statement says nothing about
the dimensions and therefore this is
false every vector space has a
corresponding dual vector space that's
correct
because if we think about what the dual
vector space was and it was just the
linear maps from the vector space itself
into the underlying field which is our
in our case and of course you can always
construct
these maps and put those together this
is the dual vector space the set of
everywhere positive functions on our
with point wise addition and s
multiplication is a vector space no it's
not since there's no neutral element you
do not have to zero in here B what is
true about tensors and their components
the tensor product of two tensors is a
tensor this is certainly correct since
it's defined in that way you can always
reconstruct a tensor from its components
and the corresponding basis that's true
as well since one can write T equals t
IJ e I tensor product ej for example
here for a zero two tensor so that's
true the number of indices of the tensor
components depends on dimension that's
false the range of the indices of the
tensor components depends on dimension
but the number of the indices has
nothing to do with that the Einstein
summation convention does not apply to
tensor components yes it does so the
statement is false the summation
convention means that if we have indices
up and the same index down then there's
something like an invisible sum and we
sum up to the dimension of the vector
space a change of basis does not change
the tensor components yes it does
since the tensor components are defined
by plugging in the basis vectors C given
a basis for a D dimensional vector space
V one can find exactly d squared dual
basis for the corresponding dual vector
space V star
that's incorrect since there's precisely
one dual basis to a given basis of beam
that's the condition that has to hold
that means epsilon are the basis vectors
of B star and E are the basis vectors of
V and I'm sorry this has to be a B and
if this condition holds then epsilon is
called dual basis of the dual vector
space and this is a linear equation
system and can be solved precisely in
one fashion given a basis for a d
dimensional vector space V by removing
one basis vector of the basis of V a
basis for a D minus 1 dimensional vector
space V 1 is obtained that's correct you
can think of r3 equipped with addition
and multiplication and we pick the
easiest basis that's 1 0 0 0 1 0 and 1 0
0 1 and we remove one of these basis
vectors then we arrive at our to the
plane and this is d minus 1 dimensional
in this case two-dimensional so that's
true and applies for all vector spaces 3
given a basis for a d dimensional vector
space V the continuity of a map F from V
to W depends on the choice of basis for
the vector space W no it doesn't
continuity is defined for topological
spaces and there's nothing set about a
topology on V or W given a base for a d
dimensional vector space V one can
construct the components of the elements
of the dual vector space V Star you can
do that because are you it's the only
way because the components are defined
by plugging in the
cases given a vector space for a
d-dimensional given a basis for a D
dimensional vector space V each vector
space of V can be reconstructed from its
components that's correct as well since
it's the same as we showed here because
you can think of vectors as zero one
tensors and then that's here we continue
with exercise two vector spaces we want
to build the vector space R 3 and think
about its dual and so on so we start
with our 3 that's just the set of all
real Triplets first question we equipped
the set V with addition and s
multiplication defined by the entry wise
addition and the entry wise
multiplication which comes from R and
now we need to check that we equipped
with this addition and this
multiplication is a vector space what we
need to do is check the vector space
axioms there are eight of them and we
start with commutativity of the addition
we call it C plus and what we have to
check is whether a b c plus d EF is
equal to the same with ABC and DF
exchanged so we apply the definition and
that's just a plus d b + e and c plus F
and of course since we know that the
addition on R is commutative we may
exchange the sums in the entries
therefore it looks like this and now we
can do the same backwards and right D
comma a comma F and come on too much
plus a comma B comma C and that's
exactly what we wanted to see next axiom
is the associativity of + that means if
we sum three elements
that's a b c + + now we put a bracket
here d e f plus G H I this needs to be
the same with the brackets around the
first two summons and what we do is we
say ABC plus and here we apply to the
definition and that means d + g ii sorry
plus h and f plus i and of course again
the definition what means a plus d + g b
+ e + h + c plus F + I and now we know
that addition on R is associative so we
can put the brackets in here so a + D B
and E and C and F are now in brackets
and continue here we pull all of these
out and then we remain with a comma B
comma C + D comma Y comma F bracket plus
and now G H I
that's what we wanted to show next one
is easy we need a neutral element for
the addition and we think of one call it
n and say this is zero zero zero and
what we have to check is that any
element of the vector space or the set
first we do not know if it's a vector
space and if we add a neutral element
then it needs to stay the same and of
course by the definition this is this
and we know that zero is the neutral
element of the real numbers and this is
of course ABC and that's true last one
four plus is the existence of an inverse
that means we need corresponding to each
element of B another element such that
their sum is the neutral element so we
start with a b c let's say and now we
need well call it for instance capital a
and now we need some a to the minus 1 I
just call it like that and we define
this as minus a minus B minus C and what
needs to be checked is that capital A
plus capital a inverse is M so we start
a plus B a comma B comma C plus minus a
minus B minus C again by the definition
we have I minus a B minus B C - C in
each entry and therefore this is 0 0 0
and that's a neutral Elam
so the first four axioms are checked we
continue with the associativity of the S
multiplications called a dot maybe you
should have the Serbs around here
because we wanted to indicate that these
are different operations than the ones
in the entries so we have to check that
lambda times mu times some element of B
is the same as the brackets around
lambda and mu so we start calculating
this is lambda times mu times a mu times
B u times C in the entries and again by
the definition we have lambda times mu
times a lambda times mu times B and
lambda times mu times C and now since we
know the multiplication on R is
associative we can put brackets around
here so this is true and now we do the
inverse thing and pull this out and what
remains is we have here multiplication
we remain with lambda times mu in
brackets times ABC okay
now we have the first distributive axiom
call it D 1 that means we have to check
that lambda plus mu and here it's a plus
on our because lambda and view come from
R times an element of B this has to be
the same as lambda times this element
and me plus nu times this element and
again we apply the definition of the
Cirque dot and this is lambda plus mu in
brackets times a lambda plus mu in
brackets times B and lambda plus mu
times C okay now we know that we can do
the multiplication here and what remains
in the entries is lambda a plus mu a
lambda B plus mu B and lambda C plus mu
C and this yields lambda times a comma x
sorry I've got this all the time ABC
plus now it's a plus on B mu times a
comma B comma C that's what we wanted to
show second last one is the second
distributive law and that says that
lambda times a b c plus d e f and this
has to be lambda times a b c plus lambda
times d EF now we apply the definition
all together and we have lambda times a
Plus D lambda
times II sorry B plus e and lambda times
c plus F so now we know that this is
lambda times a plus lambda times D and
the same for the other entries and then
we do it backwards and arrive at lambda
times a comma B comma C plus lambda
times D comma y comma F and the last one
is you serve touch
that's the existence of a unitary
element for the S multiplication and we
pick one and say it's called you and
it's the one from R and what needs to be
checked is that you times a comma B
comma C is the same as a comma B comma C
times U is a comma B comma C now we plug
it in and say this is one time sorry and
I really always forget these sharks
around here this is one circuit P comma
C applying the definition this is one
times a 1 times B 1 times C and of
course this is the same as a times 1 B
times 1 C times 1 and of course the 1 is
a mutual element of multiplication on R
and therefore this is a b c and now all
the 8 axioms are checked here forgot a
check mark here as well and to summarize
maybe so we always picked these triples
from v and lambda mu the Greek letters
come from the field underlying that is
our in our case and that's fine I guess
okay now we know that we equipped with
this plus and this circ dot
multiplication is a vector space and now
we consider objects on this vector space
the first one we want to look at is a
map called D that takes us from V to V
and it does precisely this and the
question is is D linear so what we have
to check is if D apply it to and now
lambda times ABC and I will drop the
Serb dot and the surplus because it's
much writing effort and I guess it's
clear I hope it's clear it should be
clear plus and now d EF and the question
is is this the same as lambda times D of
a b c plus d of d EF
maybe you should call this D tilde and
what we want to have here is two
brackets and that's really on purpose
because we plug in the triple and not
each of the entries so I try to keep
this and well that's a question and now
we just know what this is so this is
lambda a plus D tilde lambda B plus E
and lambda c plus F okay now we can
apply the definition of D and therefore
what remains is lambda times D plus E
and now twice lambda c plus f
and here the zero that's the definition
of D and now we want to know if that's
the same as this line so what we want to
do is pull out the lambda now what we're
going to do first is say this is lambda
B comma lambda times 2 C + 0 + and now
we have e comma 2 times F comma 0
next step is pulling out the lambda and
this is lambda B 2 C 0 + e comma 2 f 0
and of course this is the same as lambda
D applied to a b c plus d applied to e f
g that's right this is d e f we'll use
this one so here we have D tilde e comma
F and here I guess that's fine
so we checked that the map D is linear
and therefore we may write the tilde on
the arrow
the excess has continues and the next
thing to show is that the map D after D
is linear so first we write down this
map and then we check linearity so this
map D after D will certainly take us
from V into V and the question is is it
linear and we can write down what it
does it takes a triple and the stripper
is mapped to D after D applied to this
triple and this is D applied to the
first D acting on the triple produces B
comma to C 0 and the next D acting on
there makes it to C comma zero comma
zero and this has to be linear therefore
we need to check if D after D applied to
lambda a b c plus d e f and again we
call it d tilde so we start calculating
the after D now we put these together in
here so we have lambda a plus D tilde
comma then we have lambda B plus E and
we have lambda C + F okay now we know
what D after d-does it takes the last
entry and puts it in the first entry but
twice so what remains is just 2 times
lambda C + F in the first entry and two
zeros and of course we can split these
and now we have lambda
on to see alright you need the other
entries as well so comma 0 comma 0 + and
here we have 2 F comma 0 ma 0 and this
is right next line this is lambda times
D after D applied to a comma B comma C +
D after D applied to D tilde e comma F
and that's what we wanted to see next
question now we consider a map i that
goes from B to R so from the vector
space itself in to the field underlined
there and it does this with the entries
and first we should check linearity
therefore we do the same i of lambda of
a b c + d e f and we start calculating
again so this is i times lambda a + D
next entry is lambda b + e and we have
lambda c + f okay now we know what this
is this is lambda a plus d plus 1 over 2
lambda b + e plus 1 over 3 and here it
is lambda c + F now we do a little
reordering here so the lamp top floats
out of a + 1 / 2 B plus 1 over 3 C
this whole thing plus D plus 1 over 2 e
plus 1 over 3 F and this is lambda I of
a C plus I of d e f so this is linear
therefore here and the question that's
asked here is of what set is I an
element and we know I is an element of V
star because we star the linear maps
from V to our and since we checked
linearity and I goes from V to R that's
an element of the dual vector space now
we consider a map g that takes two
elements from V cross V 2 R and it's
defined as written down here and again
we should check linearity of G in fact
multi linearity that means it should be
linear in each entry so this is the
first entry and this is the second entry
and for each of these entries linearity
has to hold and I'm not going to route
write down everything just we need to
show that G of lambda times V plus W and
here we say X so V W and X come from V
and lambda comes from our and what we
need to check is whether this is the
same as lambda pulled out times G of D
comma X plus G of W comma X if this
holds G is linear in the first entry and
we do the same thing for the second
entry and then we check that G is multi
linear and
if that's the case and it is the case
then we know that G is a tensor G and
more precisely a zero to ten sir now in
the last question we will understand why
these maps G and I show them again so
this G and this map I why they are
defined in the way they are defined so
why is this a plus 1 over 2 B plus 1
over 3 C and this is this long stuff
here now we will understand why this has
been done because when you remember in
the lecture we had the set of
polynomials which we called P and now
here we want to look at just the
polynomials up to degree 2 and I will
define them again for you so P 2 is now
the set of all P that are maps from R to
R with the condition that P of X is
equal to a plus BX plus C X square just
the quadratic polynomials and now we
want to set P 2 and our vector space R 3
in relation and we will understand the
map G capital G and small G from the
lecture and small I from here and
capital I from the lecture and as well D
that was defined up here I will show it
to you oh it's on the other page sorry
I'll read this down and the map Delta
from the lecture so small D was a map
that takes an element of r3 and produces
another element of R 3 that is it took a
triple ABC and that's mapped to
of ABC and that was just this shift so
b2c and 0 and similarly we had in the
lecture tell of a polynomial P so we had
this P that is mapped over here and in
order to define this we need to oh I'm
sorry we know that this was the
derivative of P so P Prime and in order
to write this down we plug in an x and
this is b plus 2c x plus 0 times x
squared and from the way i write this
you will recognize that this map D and
the map Delta they do similar things so
they move the entries of this vector and
they move the coefficients up to here
because that's the derivation of this
the derivative of this I'm sorry and so
maybe there's a connection between these
two maps and the connection is precisely
this J this J that takes a polynomial
and maps it into r3 and now I have to
write down this polynomial I'm sorry
Arif to write down this map J that means
it takes a little P and this P is mapped
to J of P which is a B see if the
polynomial has been a plus BX plus C X
square and similarly one can construct
the inverse map that goes from r3 to p2
so it takes some ABC and these are
mapped to J inverse
of ABC and if we evaluate this many
brackets here if we evaluate this at X
this is precisely a plus BX plus CX
squared that's why the map J is defined
and the smaller gets clearer if we draw
a diagram I will do this here that means
we have P 2 2 P 2 that was the map Delta
and down here we have our 3 2 R 3 that
was the map D and we have this
connecting map G J and what's clear now
is D that takes us from our three to our
three it's the same as if we go up here
over there and down here so we first
apply J to the minus one then Delta and
then J to go down here so this is the D
and similarly you can do this
construction for the other maps that I
mentioned the G and the small GDI and
the capital I and I'm going to write
down this for I and capital I guess
the space should be enough so we have
the map by that takes us from V to our
maybe that's better notation so this one
here that's the map I and in the lecture
we had the map capital I that takes us
from the polynomials into the reals and
again we can find
this map J between P 2 and V and
therefore one can write AI equals and
now we go
J I after J so what we learned from here
is that we find structure preserving
maps between vector spaces so P 2 also
vector space and R 3 was a vector space
and this map J helps to connect these
vector spaces and you can write down the
1 map in terms of the other map so
that's it for the second exercise so the
third exercise is all about indices you
consider a vector space V that is d
dimensional and we have two tensors
given a 2 0 tensor a and 0 to 10 so B in
V we have a basis e1 2 e d and then the
star we have a basis epsilon 1 2 epsilon
D and the first question asks us to
define the components a a B and Bab of
the two tensors and that's really simply
simple so the components of a are
defined by a and we apply a to two basis
vectors of V star because it can eat 2
elements of B star maybe that's again
the better notation that this is just a
way it's defined and that's all we have
to do here similarly for B so these are
defined by be applied to e a comma E B
and this is the basis of V and this is
the basis of V star the next question
should recall the Einstein summation
convention and write it down in our own
words so that's easy we just have some
indices and if indices appear pairwise
up and down so up and down then they are
summed over . that's Einstein summation
convention okay so to give you an
example we have maybe a tensor T and
that has some indices and another tensor
s that has for instance these indices
and we know that we have to sum over C
and we have to sum over a that's the
summation convention so that's just an
example but yes that's clear the next
question we start with the definition we
define the square brackets around two
indices in here and that's defined as 1
over 2 times the difference of the
indices like this and the indices
exchanged and there are two things to
show so the first thing one is that we
exchange the indices in these square
brackets then we pick up a minus sign
and that's easily done by just applying
the definition so this was defined like
that hey B - a
da and now we can exchange these but we
pick up a minus sign which we put out
here and therefore what remains is this
one and we can think of that as this
year so one is shown the second one and
that's really helpful because it saves a
lot of calculation as we will see later
on so the second thing is to show that
these brackets can sorry they can be
written on the one index pair or on the
other and it doesn't matter so plugging
in the definition yields 1 over 2 times
a a B minus a BA this one now we since
these are all real numbers we can just
pull them in here and that's a a b b a b
minus a B a B a B and now we have to do
a little trick and that it doesn't
matter how the indices that are summed
over are called so it doesn't matter if
this is P P or mm or Delta Delta that
does not matter so I will rename them
and what I will do is I will remain them
as mm and therefore here we have nm so
far so good next line is we rename them
again but now M becomes a and n becomes
b and b become and a becomes B and sir n
becomes B and M becomes a so that's just
renaming again and now I see
there's the a appearing twice here the
same index with the same indices and
therefore we can pull it out that's a a
B and in there we have B a B - B B 8th
together with this 1/2 what remains is a
a B up times B and now the brackets for
the beam indices so that's helpful and
we will continue with another definition
so next question we define the round
brackets around index pairs which are
similarly defined but now a + between
them again two things to show the first
one says that it doesn't matter if we
say B round bracket a B or B round
bracket B a and again this is shown by
plugging in the definition and now we
know that the plus of real numbers is
commutative and therefore this is the
same as B B a plus B a B which is by
definition BB a second thing to show
here is that also the round brackets
transfer to the other index pair and I
guess you can do this a little more
quickly than the other thing because
it's just the same plug in the
definition again and pull this in here
so a a b and b ba and now we again
rename the index pairs but we rename a
SP and B
as a and what remains is this but a and
B exchanged so P a and a B and therefore
we can pull out the B and what remains
is the symmetrization of the indices of
a which is one-half a a B plus a B a and
B a B is out of the bracket and that's
just the long notation for the up here
introduced short notation which is a a B
in brackets times a times B a B so
that's good and now we use these results
to really show something important and
helpful because it saves a lot of
writing if you know this so to show is
that if you have index pairs that are
summed over and the one is
anti-symmetric and the other one is
symmetrized and this always yields zero
and you may remember that and just apply
it but once one times we have to to
write it out so a a b and b a b this is
like in the definition of one of these
does not matter which one so this is the
same as sorry
without the bracket a a B times B a B no
- because we plugged in the square
brackets this is a B a and down here B a
B but with the brackets okay and now we
learned that we can transfer the
brackets from down to up as we did this
calculation
okay so we do this for the second
summoned here - and now we have the
round brackets around these upper
indices now they're gone here and we
know what this means because this means
we can exchange a and B so what we do is
a a b b AV - a a b b a b and I forgot
the round brackets around the B it does
not actually it does not matter if I
pull them here or not
so could leave this but that's okay too
and now what you see is here's the same
thing is here so this is zero and I'm
not sure if I mentioned this already but
we call these square brackets the anti
symmetries asian and the round brackets
we call this symmetrization of index
pairs last exercise for this problem
sheet on multi linear algebra is about
how we can see or understand linear maps
as tensors so the example given here is
that we have a vector space V and on its
dual so on V star we have a linear map
Phi that takes us from we start to V
Star and the first question is we should
construct a 1:1 tensor T sub Phi by
using that Phi is precisely this map so
a 1 1 tensor you know is a map from the
star cross V linearly into the reals
that means we take some Sigma from the
star and the V
from V and this defines the map T sub 5
and now we need to define this and since
we know that Phi is a map from V star to
B star and since Sigma comes from B star
we can apply Phi 2 Sigma and the result
again lies in the star since this is the
map that's given and elements of the
star you all know are homeomorphisms
source Rd is the set of all linear maps
from V to R that means it can eat an
element of V and we have one here so
that's the definition the next question
does the same thing but the other way
around so we are given the tensor T from
V star to V it's again a 1 1 tensor and
now we should construct a linear map
from this tensor so I write this down
again Phi T should take us from the dual
vector space we start linearly into the
dual vector space we star so it takes a
sigma and that's mapped to Phi sub T of
Sigma and this we have to define by
using T and the only way we can do this
is to write T of the first entry takes
an element of the star and we have one
that's Sigma and there's an entry that's
open open tslot so to say and if we look
at this we see that we can plug in a
vector V and what we get is a real
number
so this thing is an element of V star as
it should be so that's first first
definition second definition and now
there's something to show and that is
that our definitions are good
definitions we want to reconstruct T
from the T sub Phi so we look at T sub
Phi sub T and this is a map from V Star
Plus V to R that is a 1 1 tensor I'll
write this down again
so here linearly and that means we plug
in a sigma from V Star and AV from V and
this is map to T sub Phi sub T of Sigma
comma V and now we do not have to define
anything because we did this in the
first two questions so the first we need
is T sub something and he said something
is the something of the first entry
applied to the second entry so what we
need here is this is Phi sub T of the
Sigma but this whole thing applied to V
and we also know what Phi sub T is
because that's the second thing that's
been defined so this is the tensor T of
Sigma open slot and of course it again
acts on on V so this thing is an element
of V Star and it acts on a V but if we
write the V in here or put it into the
open tslot that
really does not matter so we arrived at
what we wanted to show and again I
forgot the second pair of brackets here
okay so a finished B we wanted to show
or we have to show that T sub Phi sub T
sub Phi which is a map from B star to
the staff linearly that this reproduce
is the Phi that's given in the first
place so it takes a sigma that's mapped
to Phi sub T sub Phi of Sigma and this
is applying the definitions that we made
here so it's T sub Phi of Sigma comma
and an open slot and now we know what T
sub Phi is because that's Phi of Sigma
but there's no V in here so that's all
and what we have is Phi sub T sub Phi
applied to some Sigma it's the same as
applying the Phi to the Sigma in the
first place so we showed a and B and
what that means is and that's the
conclusion and the last question for
this exercise sheet is that we should
conclude that a linear map Phi from B
star to B star is a 0 0 to a 1 1 tensor
so this is this year is a little bit too
much so we should better say we can
understand or consider linear maps from
the star to be star as 1 1 tensor so
consider would be the better word here
because it's not precisely the same but
we can construct the one the one from
the other and the other way around and
this is all well defined
that's good so maybe you should write
down something here so the one can be
reconstructed from the other . and one
last note is that if we would if we had
chosen a map let's say sy that goes from
V to V we could also think of that as a
1:1 tensor by a similar construction
that we did up here one could prove that
but it's a little bit more sophisticated
because you have to use and that's
really not to this question but you
would have to use that the star star is
isomorphic to V and to show that you
probably need one page and this not this
is not done here but you can figure it
out so thanks and see you in the next
tutorial